yeah did you see that um I guess this
woman who's trying to like sue I think
is invited Coco because I guess she
drank into she drank a little bit of a
vitae Coco and it seemed like thick and
mushy so she and she felt like she
what's a fighter Coco coconut coconut by
Rihanna is the assurance about a Coco I
don't want to like [ __ ] on a product
anyways I'm pretty sure it was vitae
Coco
so she was it wasn't [ __ ] and she like
vomited because it was disgusting and so
she like opened up the box of the
vehicle and inside it it looked like a
[ __ ] like bed squid can I just show
you the picture please because it's so
funny
dad's yeah but the thing is is that like
Fig Newtons it's guaranteed right
there's 30% of its cockroach 30% but
yeah that's yeah yeah they actually like
harvest cockroach no way I'm gonna go
look it up Fig Newton Ryan roaches
Newton yeah you know Newton cockroach
these eggs have a lot of proteins the
safest thing be that case get your fig
newtons with the promo jelly I'm gonna
look up something cheesecake penis skin
in case this is bugs rat hairs and here
you go pigpig fig paste is allowed to
have up to 13 insect heads per a hundred
grams let me allow the ingredient but
they're allowed to have a little one is
then they'll pass yeah not 14 cockroach
heads only 13 14 you got to put it on
the ingredients yeah babe look at what
that lady found inside her vitae Coco
let me see let me see
where they found all that in Irvine
ex-officio really good what the [ __ ] can
you sue
no show the camera that oh my god you
can sue you have to right yeah pretty
funny and you know vitae Coco's respond
was like oh that's just random spoilage
guy Oh a giant squid yeah that's crazy
but I'm really sad about it because
these things are made in the Philippines
and another mommy's gonna [ __ ] on the
beach that's why I'm not shocked by it
that's normal that I mean that if you
look up Philippines that should be the
symbol also the mascot just put eyes on
it a little mouth also fig newtons are
also manufactured but this is one of my
biggest pet peeves with people traveling
people would travel but don't eat the
street food because they're like yeah
that's not hygienic okay or like people
who like see food prep and people aren't
using gloves and they're like I can't
eat that cuz he used his bare hands like
[ __ ] shut up like what that I can't do
that type of like it's snobby little I
only eat really clean [ __ ] like that's
so when I was in India there's like this
thing called Bani puddi which is like
little little like pastries that are
hard with like water and like delicious
stuff inside them so I went to Juhu
beach to have them since I didn't know
about any other place I was sick for a
month afterwards but like would you eat
it again well they're like four months
later I uh I was like I'm leaving for
the US I'm kind of better at I'm getting
me pani poni today before I get the
night before I leave
got home again sick for a full month as
I completely deserved
I'm so happy finally my mom made me go
to a doctor like yeah you need to go on
some strong whatever something different
was gonna happen as a result
yeah you just try to [ __ ] live your
lives what's that old saying
what insanity is doing the same thing
over and over expecting different
results I was more going Nietzsche you
know whatever doesn't kill you makes you
stronger and it does not it just tears
out your insight yeah over well if it's
not always though because God if I grew
up in the Philippines and I generally
think that my stomach is used to be a
little stronger when I was living there
when I came over here I started eating
all this like super clean [ __ ] I guess
so when I go back home I always get sick
but all my family members back home
their all their stomachs are made of
steel
nothing gets them sick like nothing yeah
I eat even a little I accidentally
swallow water from brushing my teeth
over there
[ __ ] it like I have diarrhea for two
weeks but also I welcome diarrhea
[Music]